[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous propose de découvrir
la NIS la nationale traverse les
ivelines de Montini le bretonux jusqu'à
ABL en passant par des villes
emblématique comme trappe ou rambouillé
je vais vous faire découvrir les trésors
qui entourent cette national 10 et ce
qu'on peut faire sur son trajet c'est
parti on noublie pas les lunettes il y a
du soleil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui ça y est on arrive sur cette
national
[Musique]
10 première étape le marché des
Merisiers de trappe c'est seulement à 2
minut même
pas de la National
[Musique]
10 pour notre première halte passage
obligé au marché des Merisiers de trappe
ici on sent les épices ici on peut
goûter à toutes les cultures du monde et
surtout boire un excellent thé à la
menthe je confirme il est
excellent
[Musique]
ce sont les spécialités du
Sénégal ça a l'air super
[Musique]
bon des
pastels avec une sauce aux
oignons très bon on reprend la route
maintenant retour sur la National 10
direction la commanderie des Templiers à
hencour c'est ici à la ville Dieu que
les célèbres Templiers ses moines
soldats se sont implantés entre 1150 et
1180 l'ensemble se compose d'une
chapelle de style gothique datant du 13e
siècle et du bâtiment des gardes un
témoin de l'histoire fascinant à
observer pour tous les amateurs du
Moyen-Âge depuis 2006 une statue en
bronze a été installée devant la
Commanderie a été sculpté par Hans Marx
après être passé à côté de morpa nous
nous dirigeons vers coanière une ville
principalement connue pour sa zone
commerciale mais pas que il y a une
superbe église qui s'appelle l'église
Saint-Germain
[Musique]
d'osser cette église romane de coignère
construite en gredda du 12e siècle elle
appartient aujourd'hui au diocèse de
Versailles dans l'église un vitrail du
16e siècle est inscrit en 1908 comme
monument historique à côté dans le
cimetière de l'église on peut également
observer des tombes de guerre du
[Musique]
Commonwealth un lieu où le temps semble
s'arrêter mais le clocher qui fracasse
le ciel et sa cloche qui raisonne nous
ramène à la réalité il faut repartir sur
cette national
10 on quitte cette commune de coignère
l'occasion pour nous de contempler une
nouvelle fois la diversité des pays AG
que l'on peut voir sur la N10 une route
qui côtoie à la fois les villes
urbanisées et le monde rural le regard
de notre caméraman Julien se laisse
parfois porté sur un tracteur le temps
de notre trajet un peu plus loin on
décide de sortir de la NIS pour se
rendre aux étants de Hollande en
traversant les
forêts à moins de 35 minutes de notre
lieu de départ à Montil broteneux et à
un petit peu moins de 10 minutes de la
National 10 je vous propose une pause
fraîcheur avec les étend de Hollande
alors les étend de Hollande c'est quoi
ce sont des étant qui ont été créés au
17e siècle par Louis XIV afin de retenir
l'eau du plateau de rambouiller afin
d'alimenter les célèbres fontaines du
château de Versailles aujourd'hui c'est
un lieu de plaisance où on profite du
soleil et du sable nous allons justement
rencontrer quelques personnes sur la
[Musique]
plage ça reste quand même un convivial
on va dire un petit endroit on peut tous
se rejoindre entre amis entre famille
essayer de passer un bon moment quand
même on a fait du pédalau ce matin là on
fait un petit molky on va faire un mini
golf on essaie de profiter un maximum
c'est super sympa il fait super beau en
plus aujourd'hui donc c'est très
[Musique]
agréable parfois sur ce lieu aux étands
de Hollande on peut voir plus de
2500 personne quand il y a de fortes
chaleurs nous malheureusement on n pas
le temps de s'éterniser ici parce qu'on
reprend la
[Musique]
route nouvelle étape dans notre périple
sur la National 10 rambouillé la ville
royale compte un peu plus de 27000
habitants premierre arrêt à la Bergerie
Nationale de Rambouillet un lieu
emblématique des
[Musique]
ivelines
alors pourquoi la Bergerie Nationale est
un lieu emblématique Frédéric alors
c'est emblématique parce que ça a été un
lieu d'expérimentation depuis plus de
200 ans parce qu'en 1786 Louis X grand
amateur de chasse et surtout
d'agriculture décide de de faire une
ferme expérimentale qui très vite
devient une bergerie royale avec
l'arrivée des mérinos au début c'était
vraiment pour travailler sur la
climatation des animaux en général mais
aussi des végétaux raison pour pour
laquelle il y a à la fois une
exploitation agricole la cour royale et
un ancien arboretum et finalement le
côté végétal est abandonné pour que
cette ferme royale devienne une bergerie
royale et il y a combien de moutons
maintenant ici donc il y a il y a
toujours le mouton historique le mérinos
de rambouillé mais depuis on a développé
d'autres races mais en toutour on peut
compter 400 moutons pas loin de 500 à
600 naissances tous les ans bon je vais
les rencontrer justement ils sont là-bas
juste derrière exactement dans la
bergerie impériale bergerie royale
bergerie impériale et maintenant
Bergerie Nationale mais effectivement
actuellement ils sont dans la bergerie
impériale je vais aller les
[Musique]
voir on envoie des choses sur la
National 10 on part de montinib teneux
et on se retrouve à rouiller avec les
[Musique]
moutons
on reprend la route pour quelques
minutes seulement direction le château
de Rambouillet construit au 14e
[Musique]
siècle derrière ces murs se cache une
partie de l'histoire de France le roi
François Ier meurt d'une septicémie dans
la demeure en
1547 près de 400 ans plus tard durant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale le 23 août 1944
le général de Gaulle le général Lecler
se rencte pour achever la stratégie de
la reconquête de Paris le Château de
Rambouillet fut le siège de plusieurs
rencontres internationales comme le
sommet du G6 en
1975 en présence du président de la
République de l'époque Valéri
giscardestin du chanelier allemand elmou
Schmidt et du président des États-Unis
gerérald Ford la salle est d'ailleurs
visible dans le château aujourd'hui on
peut visiter une partie du château pour
découvrir ses salles et ses trésors
allez en voiture il nous reste encore
quelques kilomètres à
parcourir
notre aventure sur la National 10 se
termine ici dans les ivin au niveau de
la commune d'abli au total on a parcouru
une quarantaine de kilomètres dans les
ivines à partir de montigi le bretonux
la National 10 qui continue au-delà du
département des ivines elle passe même
par Bordeaux ou encore Biaritz pour
terminer à la frontière espagnole nous
on va s'arrêter
là
[Musique]